in the world of marvel whose family
reunion is stacked with the most
powerful characters of all
from asgardian gods to thanos's skeevy
bro
here are the most powerful siblings in
the marvel universe ranked
individually the guthries might not have
the raw power of some of the other
families on this list
but they sure as heck have him
outnumbered sam guthrie aka cannonball
made his debut in the first new mutant
story back in 1982
as a simple teenage coal miner from
cameron county kentucky who discovered
he had the mutant power to blast off
sam's southern working-class roots also
brought with them a massive family
all told he was one of 10 siblings and
over the years
five of them have developed mutant
powers with most of them winding up with
the x-men
in addition to sam's nigh invulnerable
blastin and possible immortality
there's paige also known as husk who can
tear her skin off to reveal a layer of
whatever she chooses beneath
josh aka icarus has angelic wings and a
healing factor
melody aka arrow can fly knowing's
necessary
and then there's jeb who can shoot
electricity out of his face
as for the others it might be more
accurate to say that they don't have
mutant powers
yet if the comics have taught us
anything it's that there's always
another guthrie to call up to the big
leagues if you need one
the von strucker twins andrea and
andreas were pretty much
doomed to become super villains before
they were even born
after all their father baron wolfgang
von strucker was one of hitler's best
pals and he spent the past 80 years
fighting captain america and
infiltrating shield
there are only so many ways your life
can go from there and racist aryan super
villains is definitely the most likely
it's not just nurture that's the problem
though here's how they became the marvel
universe's most
uncomfortable characters on every level
while their still unnamed mother was
pregnant
wolfgang got biofanatic nazi cyborg
arnhem zola to meddle with his unborn
kids
turning them into genetically engineered
mutants the twins had the ability to fly
and blast energy out of their hands but
only while they were making physical
contact with each other leading to a
whole lot of comics where they fought
the x-men while holding hands and
implying a few
other things when it comes to bad dads
damon and satan hellstrom might have the
worst but with the fact that he's satan
and all
despite their devilish heritage satana
and daemon who occasionally goes by the
somewhat
on the nose superhero name son of satan
aren't quite as powerful as you might
expect
but it's worth noting that even after 40
years of comics they're still pretty
young by demon standards
for the most part they have the same
sort of vague magical powers possessed
by most of the mystical characters in
the marvel universe
but daemon also has the ability to shoot
fire out of his pitchfork made of
netherania
a metal mined exclusively in hell that
burns your soul instead of your body
satan on the other hand was raised in
hell and when she came to earth it was
as a fully powered succubus with the
ability to devour souls if that wasn't
enough
she also spent most of her life with her
soul bonded to an extremely powerful
demon called basilisk which she could
release to do other stuff like
blow up cars together the siblings are
pretty formidable but far from the most
powerful supernatural forces you're
likely to encounter in the marvel
universe
the summers family has been at the
center of the x-men saga
since there's been an x-men saga to be
at the center of
scott better known as cyclops appeared
in the first issue
and his brother alex who took the
codename havoc showed up not too long
after
this is my brother scott hey scott i'm
hank mccoy i'm one of the teachers here
for a long time the hints that they had
a third brother formed the basis of one
of the most intriguing mysteries of the
series
eventually readers found out that their
long-lost brother was gabriel summers
alias vulcan and there was actually a
pretty good reason cyclops and havoc
didn't know about him
see he'd been born on another planet
after his parents were kidnapped by
aliens
and their dad became a space pirate with
a sexy skunk lady girlfriend
plus while professor x found gabriel
when he came back to earth
he never bothered to tell his favorite
student because he didn't want to
individually the three summers brothers
are formidable
cyclops has optic blasts that are
capable of smashing through robots
buildings and all manner of
supervillains havoc is capable of
disintegrating virtually anything with
his powers at their peak intensity
and he once survived being thrown into a
sun
as for gabriel he was referred to as
terrifyingly powerful by adam warlock
whose status as a space messiah makes
him an expert on overpowered cosmic
characters
altogether they'd be nearly unstoppable
but alas their family squabbles
usually keep them from teaming up for
too long
usually mutants who are related to each
other have some similarities in their
powers
the summers family for instance all have
some kind of energy projection
the products on the other hand are all
over the map in terms of powers
specifically the map of great britain
betsy is well known as the on-again
off-again x-man called
psylocke whose psychic powers manifest
themselves in some pretty unique ways
not only can she do the standard mind
reading and telekinesis
she can also concentrate her abilities
into a weapon representing the focused
totality of her mutant powers
which can take the form of a psychic
knife a katana or
even a bow and arrow despite being
betsy's twin
brian braddock isn't a mutant instead he
got powers through mystical means when
he took the amulet of right and became
captain britain
with all the powers of the british isles
he can lift 90 tons
fly faster than the speed of sound keep
a stiff upper lip
take t at four and keep calm and carry
on
and then there's jaime eldest of the
braddock siblings jamie is the family's
resident supervillain
and since villains need to provide a
pretty intense challenge
he is in theory at least way more
powerful than his siblings
he sees the world as being held together
by strings and by playing puppet master
with them he can alter reality to suit
his whims
needless to say this doesn't have a
great impact on his mental health
as the team that kicked off stan lee and
jack kirby's reinvention of superhero
comics as we know them
the fantastic four have always been
marvel's first family
and the key word there has always been
family because really if you're reed
richards a super genius trying to beat
the commies into space
why wouldn't you take your girlfriend
her kid brother and a buddy from college
that's how the storm siblings susan and
johnny were exposed to the cosmic rays
that turned them into the invisible
woman and the human torch respectively
forever changing their family dynamic as
the human torch johnny has the flashiest
powers
when he flames on his body is
transformed into a plasma form that at
rest is burning at about 780 degrees
fahrenheit which for comparison is about
the temperature of molten lava
now picture that but everywhere
with that only as the starting point he
can eventually get up to 1 million
degrees fahrenheit
but even with johnny capable of
incinerating a small moon
sue is always referred to as the most
powerful member of the team
her invisible force fields are tough
enough to withstand the gravity of a
black hole the most crushingly powerful
force in the known universe
also they're pretty tough to see it says
something about the maximoffs that their
estranged half-sister lorna better known
as the superheroine polaris is generally
considered to be on the same
world-beating level of sheer strength as
her father magneto
and she still isn't quicksilver's most
powerful sibling
not even by a long shot don't get it
wrong both polaris and quicksilver are
incredibly powerful in their own right
lorna is strong enough to wreck a
spaceship with her magnetic powers and
has such fine control over her abilities
that she can manipulate the iron in
someone's body to reverse their blood
flow
pietro better known as quicksilver isn't
the fastest runner in the world of
superhero
comics but he can still get to mach 4 on
foot and punch you a thousand times
before you can blink
wanda on the other hand is on a whole
other level partly because her magically
augmented mutant powers are so vaguely
defined that they're basically limitless
for a long time the scarlet witch was
shown to have control over probability
but she also remade the entire marvel
universe and stripped the powers away
from millions of mutants
just by saying the words no more mutants
of course
take this ranking with a grain of salt
not because these three characters
aren't powerful but because they might
not be siblings
as of this video lorna is magneto's
child while pietro and wanda aren't
but who knows what the next person who
writes avengers is going to reveal
t'challa and shuri of wakanda who've
both held the identity of black panther
are both extremely powerful people for
many different reasons and each sibling
has their own unique gifts
politically wakanda is one of the marvel
universe's most powerful nations thanks
to being one of two places on earth with
the supply of vibranium the supermetal
that powers both their economy and the
black panther's arsenal of high-tech
weaponry
on a personal level both shuri and
t'challa have gained the superhuman
abilities from the semi-mystical
heart-shaped
herb granting them strength speed and
reflexes far beyond
ordinary people honestly though that's
the least of their powers
they're both brilliant but shuri's
facility with technology and inventing
puts her on par with the other super
scientists of the marvel universe
and t'challa well he's the king of the
dead
a title that he got from the goddess
boss the full extent of what that means
has yet to be revealed but it did give
him the ability to command a couple
hundred thousand zombies and lead them
as a revolutionary army when doctor doom
took over the multiverse
thanos has been well established as one
of the biggest baddest villains of the
marvel universe on both the big screen
and the comics page
he's the guy who kills countless
billions without a second thought and
who literally worships death
which he thinks of as a lady he wants to
take out for a nice dinner after a long
night of galactic genocide
but thanos isn't even the creepiest
member of his family
that honor such as it is goes to his
brother eros
the occasional avenger also known as
star fox
eros has the ability to project what he
calls overwhelming waves of pleasure
and yes that's exactly what it sounds
like
for years the implications were just
implications
but in a she-hulk story he was sued by
women that he'd seduced with his powers
and as it turns out his pleasure
inducing creep factor is so powerful
that he can never turn it off while
they're often on opposite sides
thor and loki represent the pinnacle of
asgardian power
thor's got that overwhelming hammer
swinging strength and the ability to
conjure up storms so intense that they
threatened to swallow the sun
meanwhile loki has razor sharp cunning
immortality and a powerful command of
sorcery
hey let's do get help what get help
no come on you love it i hate it they're
opposed to each other more often than
not
but as a duo they're nearly unstoppable
and they have a sister
angela's path to the marvel universe is
a complicated one
she was originally created in spawn at
image comics
then became the subject of a lawsuit
over ownership that lasted over
a decade and ended with her being sold
to marvel back in 2013.
to explain her long-lost status she was
revealed to be a resident of the secret
10th realm
she's still odin's daughter though and
has all the usual powers you'd expect
with the added bonus
of being so deadly she's considered
asgard's assassin
she's been shown to be thor's equal in
combat giving valhalla's annual family
reunion
more sheer power than any other family
gathering in the multiverse
the most powerful character in the
entire marvel multiverse
isn't thanos galactus or any other
cosmic force
in fact he's not even an adult franklin
richards the young son of the fantastic
fours reed richards and sue storm
inherited his parents considerable
cosmic powers on top of being the single
most powerful mutant ever born
what exactly can he do well anything
franklin's powers are generally
portrayed in the telepathy
telekinesis category with the small
bonus of being able to control reality
to the point of literally creating
universes
in fact when the marvel multiverse was
destroyed by doctor doom the way the
fantastic four fixed it was just having
franklin come up with a bunch of
alternate universe ideas
and then use his powers to make them
real since franklin's powers are pretty
much
infinite any group of siblings in which
he's included would by definition
rank at the top of this list but his
sister valeria isn't exactly a slouch
herself
we don't know what they are yet but she
definitely has powers
and what's more she's a super genius
even by the standards of the fantastic
four
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one